[Musique]
il y encore 70 ans bellefontaine été
qu'un hameau de case-pilote ici vivaient
des pêcheurs des maraîchers ou encore
des ouvriers agricoles
bien loin de leur commune de
rattachement un sentiment de rejet
d'abandon s'installe puis il ya la
période de l'amiral robert les
difficultés économiques et la force de
quelques-uns pour faire scission le 17
mai 1950 les bellifontain obtiennent
leur indépendance tijou avait 25 ans le
cfw newman le casual pas d'ailés un nom
je veux quand je veux aller c'est un
fait est fait ce disque et tout ça nous
bouder
c'est un baby et onu et le déclic c'est
un recensement effectué après la guerre
les bellifontain se rendent compte en
effet qu'ils sont plus nombreux que
l'ensemble des habitants de case-pilote
simon charles françois natif du quartier
comprend qu'il peut changer l'histoire
de sa commune
il se présente aux élections municipales
il y avait ce qu'on appelle les grosses
têtes j'ai envie de dire et les acteurs
de la commune le boulanger le maître
scène les gérants de distillerie qui se
sont associés pour créer donc une espèce
d'equipe ils ont battu campagne pendant
deux ans avant que ses élections
son oncle qui deviendra le deuxième
maire de la commune faisait partie de l'
aventure l'histoire de cette élection
rocambolesque se mêlent aux anecdotes
les bellifontain n'avait pas les moyens
d'aller voter
il avait en plus peur ils ont organisé
c'était des milices armées avec les
camions des les contremaîtres ont mis à
disposition les camions des
exploitations et armée parce qu'en fait
c'était très dangereux on nous raconte
des anecdotes des prêts des périodes pré
électorales où il ya du sang qui a coulé
une indépendance arrachée au pilotant
raconter aujourd'hui encore au sein des
familles une histoire commune qui a fait
l'âme des belles fontaines ont des
forces de la commune c'est d'avoir des
trains petit bourg
familiale essentiellement donc on a un
maillage social à la commune qui est
très important
maillage social et familial donc les
gens se connaissent ça crée une synergie
naturelle en fait au sein de la commune
donc ça c'est une de ses forces
je pense aujourd'hui encore ça se voit
nettement
les réseaux familiaux organise la vie de
la cité
bellefontaine et la petite dernière des
communes de la martinique
soixante dix ans célébrée dans la plus
grande discrétion
pas de fête ni cotillons pas de coup de
seine reste les souvenirs et les
témoignages à ne pas oublier